you know what you're doing you've done
some great things just because you think
you have done some we've all done
oh well look at this this got me
attention and then i did this
and then we have this that didn't do
well or at bomb i always say if somebody
has one hit movie
they've got one hit movie if they've got
one thing that i liked i go
they're great i don't care if they have
10 pieces of i remember before i
had a career
back when i was just like a film
enthusiast you know somebody that
dreamed about
making movies um you know spike lee
had made he started with she's got to
have it then he did school days and his
third film
was do the right thing and do the right
thing is an astounding achievement
that's still
one of my five favorite films of all
time and still holds up today even more
now today oddly enough than than when
they made the movie or
it's just as relevant today as in 1989
which is a sad statement on the country
so i love that movie um
a couple years later man like he did
something maybe it was girl six or
something that a bunch of people were
kind of like crapping on
and my whole thing was like hey man that
dude made do the right
thing like he gets a pass forever
right and right then i had a career
thankfully one day i heard somebody in
the depths of my career when i was doing
nobody liked
i heard somebody go like well at least
he made clerks and i was like yes
the do the right thing defense it's
gonna come in my favor as well but
that's a healthy way to look at it and
we and of course when the shit's piling
up
and we're bombing and we're like you
know oh
it's it's it's how you look at it we
look at it differently then you're
probably not as
optimistic were you you probably were
like you hit
i was terrified that like look the first
movie we made was clerks
and i'll be the first to tell you we
were insanely over praised we were in
flavor of the year
not even just the month and people said
such nice things about that movie
mall rats polar opposite experience
a bunch of i mean now people really like
the movie it's aged well but when it
came out critics like in its mouth
they did no money at the box office the
poster which
drew struzant painted is classic
as far as i'm concerned
was confusing to people because they
were like is this a magazine like it
looked like the cover of a comic book
but you know most people didn't get that
comical culture wasn't that big
at that time and
so i think to a lot of people like oh
this must be a new magazine coming out
called mall rats or something like that
so like everything that could have went
wrong went wrong and i remember being
like
we're over you know there was a moment i
was so early in my career i was like
universal gave us 5 million to make this
movie it only made two million do i owe
them three million dollars because i got
that kind of scratch
so that's an instance of me going like
we're
finished like you could find interviews
from me with me at that time
like there's a premier magazine quote
where you know i was like um
i've spent the summer like uh or i've
spent the last two weeks because i guess
male rats came out like in the beginning
of the fall or something like that and i
said i spent the last two weeks
uh curled up in the fetal position in a
dark bedroom
with a stack of bad reviews in one hand
and a shotgun in the other and stuff
and um i you know it seemed like
i'm done you know chasing amy was a hail
mary for me because i was like
we're finished like nobody's
gonna hire me that was it one hit wonder
the sophomore jinx was the most
terrifying thing in the world
to young filmmakers first time
filmmakers man if you were lucky enough
to get attention for your first film
then you had to run the gauntlet of what
people would make of your second film
and in my case
people made nothing of it they were like
ugh i remember the reviews
like uh what's his name kenny taran said
in the la times he goes
if if afi
or sundance ever offer a course on what
not to do as a second feature
mall rat should be at the heart of the
curriculum that was the nicest part of
it like all the reviews were very
dismissive and the general tone was we
put this guy
here with clerks this is the he
makes these sundance kids
like give them no money or whatever
you